fellow americans i want to speak to you
tonight
about the troubling events of the past
week
as i have said the incursion of the u.s
capitol
struck at the very heart of our republic
it angered and appalled millions of
americans
across the political spectrum
i want to be very clear i unequivocally
condemned the violence that we saw last
week
violence and vandalism have absolutely
no place in our country
and no place in our movement making
america great again has always been
about defending
the rule of law supporting the men and
women of law enforcement
and upholding our nation's most sacred
traditions and values
mob violence goes against everything i
believe in
and everything our movement stands for
no true supporter of mine could ever
endorse
political violence no true supporter of
mine could ever disrespect
law enforcement or our great american
flag
no true supporter of mind could ever
threaten or harass
their fellow americans if you do any of
these things
you are not supporting our movement you
are attacking it
and you are attacking our country we
cannot tolerate it
tragically over the course of the past
year
made so difficult because of covet 19
we have seen political violence spiral
out of control we have seen too many
riots too many mobs too many
acts of intimidation and destruction
it must stop whether you are on the
right
or on the left a democrat
or a republican there is never
a justification for violence
no excuses no exceptions
america is a nation of laws
those who engaged in the attacks last
week
will be brought to justice now i am
asking everyone who has
ever believed in our agenda to be
thinking of ways to ease tensions
calm tempers and help to promote peace
in our country there has been reporting
that additional demonstrations are being
planned
in the coming days both here in
washington
and across the country i have been
briefed by the u.s secret service
on the potential threats every american
deserves to have their voice heard
in a respectful and peaceful way that is
your first
amendment right but i cannot emphasize
that there must be no violence no law
breaking
and no vandalism of any kind everyone
must follow our laws
and obey the instructions of law
enforcement
i have directed federal agencies to use
all
necessary resources to maintain order
in washington d.c we are bringing in
thousands of national guard members
to secure the city and ensure that a
transition can occur
safely and without incident like all of
you i was shocked and deeply saddened by
the
calamity at the capitol last week
i want to thank the hundreds of millions
of incredible american citizens
who have responded to this moment with
calm moderation
and grace we will get through this
challenge
just like we always do i also want to
say
a few words about the unprecedented
assault
on free speech we have seen in recent
days
these are tense and difficult times the
efforts to
censor cancel and blacklist our fellow
citizens
are wrong and they are dangerous
what is needed now is for us to listen
to one another
not to silence one another
all of us can choose by our actions
to rise above the rancor and find common
ground
and shared purpose we must focus on
advancing the interests of the whole
nation
delivering the miracle vaccines
defeating the pandemic rebuilding the
economy
protecting our national security and
upholding
the rule of law today i am calling on
all americans to overcome the passions
of the
moment and join together as one
american people let us choose to move
forward united
for the good of our families our
communities
and our country thank you god bless you
and god bless america